well close to 900 new teachers set for
the new school year in Clark County but
1300 more are still needed while the
district is still hiring those who have
signed on are getting ready for the
first day 8 news now reporter Jeremy J
Ford live in The Newsroom after speaking
to some teachers on the process to get
them ready for Monday
yeah that's right I spoke with newly
hired teachers and I'm told the
onboarding process can be a lengthy one
but a teacher I spoke with said going
through that process will be well worth
the reward ever since I've become a
teacher I love it Devante Thorns tells
me he moved from Houston Texas to take a
job as a teacher with CCSD it came
because it was an alternative program I
wanted to see what it was like honest I
got in the program I met some good
people they they helped shape me up to
become a teacher now he's ready for
school to start after a long onboarding
process process is is it's a little
difficult it's rigorous but I mean if
you want to do something you got to see
it through right something all 883 new
teachers had to go through because
superintendent Jesus Jara says he
expects only the best from all of his
staff we are deploying every educator in
the central office onto our schools we
are deploying admin administrators who
have licenses onto our schools we want a
certified educator license in the
classroom with kids that is our priority
now superintendent Dr Zara also says
with so many new teachers on board
they're still working to get them ready
for the new school year reporting from
The Newsroom Jeremy J Ford live local
now thank you Jeremy and as of last
Wednesday the CCSD website listed more
than 2100 open positions but the
district is working hard to lower that
number as we mentioned just a few
moments ago there are about 1300 open
teacher positions more than 600 support
positions and 22 administrative jobs
according to the district it will start
the school year with a teacher in
approximately 91 percent of classrooms
and a bus driver for about 90 percent of
the rooms